bad diversity is where we have two
people who grow up in countries that
drive on opposite sides of the road and
you decide that everybody is entitled to
drive on the side of the road that they
grew up of and feel comfortable with and
all you get is auto accidents so we are
here with intellectual dark web
impresario Eric Weinstein we're going to
get started talking in just a minute
when the most fascinating guys around
but first I want to talk to you about
your internet security with all the
recent news about online security
breaches it's hard not to worry about
where my data goes making an online
purchase simply accessing your email it
could be putting your private
information at risk because you are
being tracked online by social media
sites and marketing companies and your
mobile or internet provider not only can
they record your browsing history they
often sell it to other corporations who
want to profit from that information
which is why I've taken back my privacy
by using Express VPN so expressvpn they
have easy to you at easy to use apps
that run seamlessly in the background of
your computer or phone tablet turning on
expressvpn protection only takes one
click and expressvpn secures and
anonymizes your internet browsing it
encrypts your data hiding your public IP
address protecting yourself with
expressvpn cost less than seven bucks a
month you owe it to yourself it's rated
the number one VPN service by TechRadar
it comes with a 30-day money back
guarantee so try and see if you like it
you will if you ever use public Wi-Fi
you want to keep hackers and spies from
seeing your data expressvpn is indeed
the solution and if you don't want to
hand over your online in history to
internet providers or Dayna resellers
expressvpn can help you protect that
online activity today find out how you
can get three months for free and
expressvpn comm slash pen that's expr
ESS VPN com slash been for three months
free with one year package expressvpn
com slash man to check it out and learn
more okay Eric Weinstein thank you so
much for joining me here on the Sunday
special for those who don't know Eric
Weinstein is a harvard-trained PhD in
mathematics who somehow found himself as
the creator of the intellectual dark web
which you've read about in the pages of
the New York Times omits photos of
people like Eric standing in the trees
with Sam Harris and Joe Rogan standing
among the cacti so Eric first of all
welcome thanks for coming in thanks for
everything the second of all how did you
who started off and still work in the
world of physics and mathematics ends up
creating at least the name for the
intellectual dark web you did it I know
we're on stage again
when it happened so what's the backstory
here well I think it's actually sort of
an interesting one I have been tracking
various political and social issues
since the 1980s and have inserted myself
or fought through a number of topics
including high-skilled immigration
mortgage-backed securities and various
issues having to do with my concerns
over the loss of objectivity in the
major press organs so in some ways this
is not my first rodeo there have been a
few before and what's been really
interesting for me is that this is the
first one where I've had great company
so a lot of these previous iterations
have been really one or two people like
Nassim Taleb was a co-fighter in the
mortgage-backed security question and
the guy named norm Matloff was one of
the few people who is really a critic of
high-skilled immigration from an
intelligent position so what's really
interesting about this is that this is
the first time that there's a large
number of interesting voices with a few
new technologies and and wrinkles to
explore and I think the best thing I
could think to do with so many
independent voices was to try to use
language to identify what was already
occurring and have the language sort of
help people see what was already
happening and that would allow it us to
direct this a little bit for more more
powerfully what do you think has changed
well what sort of brought all of this
together because obviously it's pretty
politically disparate group you're on
the political left you voted Democrat I
believe virtually all the time no I
don't think I've ever voted okay so yeah
so you're on the left and you know
obviously your brother Brett who's a
member of the IDW in good standing he
also is on the Left people like Sam
Harris are on the left and then I may be
the only overt conservative in the group
actually I think it's been it's been
actually perceived as this wild
right-wing group and as far as I know
I'm the only registered Republican in
the group so far as I know and I think
that has to do with the fact that
something very peculiar happened
on the left and so in many ways this is
a response from an older left to what is
viewed as almost certainly a very brief
very intense and very crazy
bout of bad judgment I would say from
the American left it's not that these
strains haven't been present before but
what's really new to me is the idea that
this new sort of woke Network which
practices something which I've called
left car theism has invaded the major
organs of civil society and the most
important examples of this I would say
first and foremost is not the
universities but the major media
companies that art form our sense making
network so news bureaus let's say the
next thing that's infected in my opinion
is the tech companies that are public
facing which are under constant pressure
to show that they are sufficiently in
line with what are called progressive
values but I think most of us with a
longer timeline would say we're very
regressive values in the intelligence
community which you know scares me no
end almost certainly has a relationship
with these tech companies given that we
deposit all our secrets into our gmail
accounts and our browsing histories is
you were just talking about in your
latest plug you know all of these things
are come together and what I call Tim
technology intelligence and media the
universities are a certain or certainly
a serious problem but I think the most
important problem is that we can't trust
our sense making organs because you know
as we just i tweeted out today the new
yorker you know ran a tweet saying
conservative orders like my louie
innopolis ben shapiro and richard
Spencer and then dot dot and I thought
wow I mean you just put ben shapiro next
to Richard Spencer's if none of us are
gonna notice what you just did this has
gotten really dirty really negative and
conservatives have complained about
excesses on the left for a long time and
I think that's been fair but I also
think that there have been a lot of
excesses on the right what we're seeing
is some
thing really really new the the the new
left is much more dangerous and I think
those of us on the on the old left who
weren't happy with some of these strains
before take it upon ourselves to say how
do we clean this up this is in some
sense our problem and you know that that
was not fair to do to you so if the New
Yorkers not going to apologize to you I
prefer not to apologize I'm just gonna
fight back because it's just not right
well you didn't do it so you shouldn't
apologize obviously so but but let's
talk about how you fix these particular
institutions and what is the exact
problem with the institution so there
have been a couple of solutions proposed
with regard to the media from the right
one is the sort of restoration of the
idea that there is an objective
journalism to be found and that
everybody should go back to this
aspirational idea that supposedly
existed before where there were the fact
checkers and the people who reported the
facts and then there were the opinion
makers and there were two separate
groups of people and then there are
folks like me who tend toward a sort of
legal realist perspective when it comes
to media which is all these folks have
their political point of view we know
they all have their political point of
view why don't they just be honest about
their political point of view I run a
right-wing website the Huffington Post
the left-wing website I have less of a
problem with CNN with MSNBC than I do
with CNN for exactly this reason because
MSNBC is clear about its bias he's how
do you think this gets solved is it
people being upfront about their own
biases or attempting to remove their own
biases in doing the reporting is that
even possible
I think both of those both of those
techniques can work just fine so you
know gonzo was the idea that if we just
open what it is that we're thinking and
doing we insert ourselves into the story
that that allows the consumer to unspin
whatever it is that they're doing or you
can have Waring you know a left-wing
media and a right-wing media that's not
what the problem is at the moment I
think that the problem is that a lot of
this stuff is just actually disingenuous
right people know that you are not a
Nazi and they know that Richard Spencer
is very close to being one you know that
he's really flirting with stuff that's
absolutely dangerous and crazy and they
don't care the key point is as somebody
said to me recently and progress is
messy and the idea is that if certain
lives have to get ruined on the way
towards some imagined egalitarian
society then that's just too
damn bad that's terrifying literally the
language of Stalinism I mean that is
breaking the eggs to make the omelet
does that is legitimately that the
quotes being used by people who are
selling us yes and you know sometimes
certain bad things have to happen but
we're talking about the actual
destruction of interesting and important
lives because the people who see this
collectively view this as a hive if a
few bees and a hive die it's not like
the hive actually collapses so because
of the collectivist framework they
actually don't see damages to individual
lives as particularly worthy of empathy
so what is going on I think is very
important you know you bring up two
models you can either try for your
objectivity who can be honest about your
biases both of those are much more
similar to each other than this other
thing is which is we know what the right
answer is for society and it doesn't
really matter how we get to get there so
what we're going to do is we're going to
propose ideas that are and in an analogy
there almost like suicide ideas they're
ideas that are simply meant to be highly
destructive so that you know if I say to
you well you know clearly a white man I
can't understand anything and what I've
just done is I've taken two of your
attributes and I've shut you up or
forced you to deal with this completely
irrelevant argument you know for the
next 90 minutes so this style of
argumentation is is something that
actually has to be excluded if you want
a diversity of opinion of opinions that
actually matter it's very important not
to seat people who think in these terms
at the table and you know this is what
we talked about another I think maybe on
the Rubin reporter maybe it was just
before you got there there's good
diversity and there's bad diversity and
so what I analogized is good diversities
we have people who are of good character
trying to puzzle through something
fighting very hard for their perspective
bad diversity is where you have two
people who grow up in countries that
drop but they drive on opposite sides of
the road and you decide that everybody
is entitled to drive on the side of the
road that they grew up of and feel
comfortable with and all you get is auto
accidents and so it's very important to
drive bad diversity out of the system
because otherwise you never get to
experience the benefits of the highly
multicultural and interesting diverse
society that we've managed to build for
us so you've spent an awful lot of time
in the tech community also so you
mentioned three specific areas mentioned
media and
the intelligence community chose so tech
you've spent a lot of time in because
you work closely with Peter Thiel who
obviously is deeply involved in
everything Silicon Valley has to offer
I've been complaining for a long time
about the inherent biases of places like
Facebook and YouTube and it's pretty
obvious to folks including Dave Dave
Rubin that YouTube has a biased
algorithm that D monetize his particular
points of view Facebook has on occasion
really punish people on the right for I
believe political reasons is there
anything can be done about this in any
real sense or we just at the whims of
what are essentially monopolies I mean
Facebook has the closest thing to a
monopoly that I've seen in modern
American life and I'm not an antitrust
guy by nature but the fact is there's no
competing service that even comes close
to the sort of control that Facebook has
over social media and people have spent
millions of dollars promoting material
on Facebook to have Facebook gobble that
up and then turn back an algorithm that
is dishonest and disingenuous in many
cases is that something that can be
dealt with or is the only answer
regulation or the building of
alternative methods of distribution yeah
I think that yeah this is a really
interesting and difficult problem I
believe that there is actually a set of
new problems that came about from the
fact that this technology giving
everybody the power of their own
newspaper let's say to publish their own
newspaper is a new feature of the world
it's not clear to me that free speech
can just go on as before because of how
big of a shift this particular new idea
is you know if I get a hold of you know
some very dangerous secrets before
anybody knows that I could have
published it on on Instagram or Facebook
or who knows what so I think that there
are actually a new suite of problems
that are probably going to have to
change jurisprudence if we're going to
keep the spirit of the Constitution
alive and I don't know what that's going
to be but I think that that's going to
be a change when these companies found
that they had these problems that people
didn't want to be on the networks
because everything was so unpleasant
when everyone was getting all
information all the time I think that
they tried to get community policing
whoever the people were complaining the
loudest if you
complaining loudly you might become a
Truth and Safety Commission member and
so effectively all of the most noisy
most upset about folks ended up in in
these positions of some power and
influence and a lot of the suggestions
that they've made have been lousy to
people who have a very strongly rational
perspective
nobody's perfectly rational but the idea
being that lots of things that we talk
about that should be discussable by
adults and in an adult fashion you know
if let's say my brother mentions
genotype and phenotype is a biologist
and someone has a freakout session
because they think that that's evidence
of his bigotry that person who's
freaking out needs to be downregulated
and not listen to so it's very important
that we not over value the loudest and
shrillest voices but the tech companies
I don't think figured out how to do that
furthermore I think that what we don't
what I don't understand is the extent to
which what I call the gated
institutional narrative or gin depended
upon their being very few outlets to
check or challenge what the major
thematic narratives would be and I think
that there's a real difficulty with
people who came up in the previous world
before the internet and before social
media trying to figure out how to exert
enough party you know level discipline
in order to have these sort of long
narratives that we remember from the era
of Walter Cronkite and Eric severide and
that's that's gone away it's never
coming back unless somebody does
something drastic so I think it's very
important to understand there were some
problems and we haven't had good
solutions but what Arendt was terrifying
me is that I don't know what part of
this might be directed and what part of
this is emergent I don't know if there
are there have always been people behind
the scenes looking to manipulate the
media and what I don't know is if those
hands are currently using the power of
these algorithms in a way that has
nothing to do with providing a more
engaging and pleasant product so it's
necessary on almost certainly we need
control over the algorithms I
need to be able to experiment and flick
a switch and say I want to see things in
the order that they were published I
want to see things without you
prioritizing this or up regulating and
down regulating that give me the toggle
switches in the control so that
fundamentally I can catch you if I see
that you were politically manipulating
so for example on Twitter I never know
which of these accounts are authentic if
I tweet something and 20 accounts have
very similar statements like hahaha what
an idiot okay that's gonna make me feel
a particular way what if those accounts
are all owned by one person and then
they're programmed to do that we don't
know which percentage of this is
effective so in a second I'm gonna ask
about the intelligence community first
let's talk about your impending doom
okay everyone is going to die 71% of
people say they need life insurance but
only 59% of people have coverage which
means at least 12% of people are
procrastinating and 29% of people are
stupid because all of you need life
insurance sure normally procrastinating
is a bad thing but if you've been
avoiding getting life insurance
procrastinating may have worked in your
favor this one's because while you are
putting it off policy genius was making
it easy policy genius is the easy way to
compare life insurance online you can
compare quotes in just five minutes and
when it's that easy putting it off
becomes a lot harder plus if you put it
off too long you die and then it's too
late you can compare of quotes while
sitting on the couch watching TV you can
compare quotes while you're listening to
this podcast go try it
policy genius has helped over 4 million
people shop for insurance they've placed
over twenty billion dollars in coverage
and they don't just do life insurance
they also do disability insurance and
renter's insurance and health insurance
if you care about it they can cover it
so if you need life insurance but you've
been busy because you're putting it off
or whatever you don't have the time
checkout policy genius it's the easy way
to compare top insurers find the best
value for you no sales pressure is zero
hassle it's free policy genius calm when
it's this easy to compare life insurance
there's no reason to put it off policy
genius calm okay so now let's talk about
the third leg of the stool that you're
having problems with here and that is
the intelligence community so obviously
President Trump has been incredibly
critical of the intelligence community I
think some of that is disingenuous I
think that the president doesn't like
when the intelligence community comes up
with answers he doesn't like he doesn't
have sort of a natural civil libertarian
objection to the intelligence community
what is it what is your chief objection
to the intelligence community and how do
we draw the balance between an
intelligence community that does what it
needs to do to protect us from terrorist
attack an intelligence community that is
gathering up every
data that it can possibly for use
against undesirable people or for
targeting of particular view points so I
think it has to do with how much history
you're aware of and in particular one of
the most disturbing things about our
intelligence community is what we found
out in the mid 70s from the church and
Pike Commission's when we really
thoroughly investigated what was going
on not only in the FBI but in particular
in the division known as COINTELPRO and
one of the things that I point people to
so that they understand just how bad the
situation can get is the situation in
which Jean Seberg one of Hollywood's
leading actresses was destroyed by
information taken from the
misinformation rather taken from the FBI
and placed in the Los Angeles Times by a
woman named Joyce Haber later repeated
by Newsweek suggesting that she had
cuckold in her white husband with a
Black Panthers child she then under
stress miscarried had an open casket
press conference displaying a dead white
fetus and went crazy eventually killing
herself after attempting to do so on
every anniversary of her child's death
this is the way in which the US has
previously played this is not a
conjecture it's not speculation this is
proven fact just as we experimented with
the idea of getting La Cosa Nostra to
kill Dick Gregory Martin Luther King's
right-hand man the letter from Sullivan
trying to get Martin Luther King to kill
himself by his own hand
and we actually assassinated Fred
Hampton in his bed in Chicago so if you
have a left-of-centre perspective you're
very well aware that the intelligence
community has previously been out of
control now I have no reason to think
that it is out of control at the same
level now I don't know if there's an
analog of operation Mockingbird but the
idea that we should simply trust our
intelligence community when we have not
publicly vigorously investigated it for
many years in a new era in which it's
possible to Hoover up all sorts of data
from our simply our daily behavior given
that all of us carry tracking devices
microphones and
cameras at all time this is patently
insane and and and we need a new level
of oversight so that we can trust our
intelligence community with our secrets
what concerns me is is that I don't know
who to trust at base I don't know if we
can trust the intelligence community
maybe we can maybe they're doing an
absolutely brilliant job without
infringing on our rights or maybe
they're out of control what is it that
we are going to do in the modern era
with all of this extra sensor data to
make sure that we are not being tracked
completely how did it so I started off
by asking you you know you start off as
a guy doing mathematics at Harvard how
did you go from there to politics how
did you get into this world like what's
your personal story first of all how did
you get into math tell me kind of how
you got here well so you have a path to
God through the synagogue my family
while Jewish was always committed li
atheist and I figured if if I was ever
going to figure out what the universe
was probably reading differential
geometry rather than Hebrew was the way
to find God in his original language so
I I thought I would try to figure out
how physics unifies and in the process
of that I responded to a call from the
scientific community that said that we
were going to have a massive shortage of
scientists and engineers back in the
1980s and that the job prospects were
going to be limitless and very well
remunerated what happened in fact is is
that we had a disaster and in trying to
figure out why the golden era
immediately disappeared in the early
1990s I discovered that there had been a
conspiracy in the National Academy of
Sciences the National Science Foundation
of policy research and analysis division
and the government university industry
research Roundtable all side of the
National Academy complex in the National
Science Bureau board what shocked me was
is that they were in fact trying to
figure out how to avoid letting the free
market determine the salaries of
scientists and engineers and letting
them rise to bring the name needed
Americans into the STEM sector and so
when I was the person who discovered a
secret study from 1986 studying
how to in fact lower the wages of
Americans by flooding the market with
foreign scientists and engineers I
couldn't believe it I had always thought
that immigration was basically a pure
positive
I was excited as all of us are that we
live in such a vibrant nation of
immigrants and then to find out then
that the very people who were supposed
to be guarding the national science
endeavor were the ones who were stab me
in the back was like finding an Agatha
Christie whodunit where it was Murder on
the Orient Express and everyone had a
hand in pushing the knife in
so that broke trust to such a remarkable
extent that I ended up testifying in
front of her presenting from the
National Academy of Sciences four
separate times and I watched as the news
media refused to cover the story
effectively everybody buried it and then
I realized my gosh we're not living in
the free society that I thought because
the story went counter narrative because
in my sector of the world all of us were
pro immigrant and this indicated that
immigrants weren't the problem but that
the visas were being used to flood the
market because this was a story of
betrayal by the government against the
workers because the claim was that
Americans couldn't do science and
engineering when I think we are
absolutely one of the very best systems
for educating people in science and
engineering the whole thing was
topsy-turvy and I think that that
institutional betrayal was the thing
that hooked me on the idea that I didn't
know how deep the rabbit-hole went so
when it comes to that issues let's talk
about high-skilled immigration for a
second because we may have a difference
of opinion on this I've always been an
advocate for high-skilled immigration
you obviously oppose high-skilled
immigration at least in certain sectors
what is the the downside of high-skilled
immigration is it just the people are
being promised jobs that aren't
materializing in the United States or is
there a detriment to the United States
with people bringing in high-skilled
immigrants to to fill jobs in in sectors
where they want to lower the price I
mean first of all I don't even know
where to begin a certain amount of
high-skilled immigration has always been
present and we do bet and benefit from
getting the absolute top talent in the
world but that's not really what we're
looking at what we're looking at is a
bunch of systems that depressed
markets so that we lose top talent that
don't that doesn't choose to go into
science and engineering that goes into
Investment Banking or management
consulting or some other sector because
these salaries are so low it means that
a lot of our technical edge which we use
to power our own economy and our own
defense structure finds its way to the
four or five countries in Asia which
supply us with most of the cryptic labor
what we call graduate study but is in
fact a labor market to staff the labs
you can even most people have never even
done the thought experiment
imagine that let's say live Nets lives
in Germany Newton and Clark live in the
UK and Newton is better than live Nets
but you open one border and not the
other and Germany pays better
well then Newton displaces live nets
Clark takes the job the space that would
have been left for Newton and you get
Clark in the UK and Newton in Germany
rather than Newton in the UK and Leibniz
in Germany so you get an inferior
outcome so I think people haven't really
thought through this idea they have an
intuitive sense of our we're getting an
incredible bargain we're getting the
best minds in the world what could
possibly be going wrong the last thing
I'm gonna say is that I think we do a
better job with our crazy heterogeneous
educational system raising irreverent
scientists and I think the biggest
discovery is the ones that really move
the needle are done by people who are
incredibly irreverent and very
disagreeable and that's what our system
excels at if you get a Richard Fineman
he's dangerous you can't really he's
like an outside cat you can't bring him
inside but the fact is what we're
getting is we're getting client labor
people who don't really rock the boat
who are extremely regular rather than
people who are confident who know that
their careers are assured and who can
flip the middle finger to anybody who
gets in their way while they're
exploring ideas so it sounds a lot like
if you take all the elements that we've
been talking about so far it sounds a
lot like you understand why Trump came
to the floor because we've now been
talking about high-skilled immigration
and its downsides you've been talking
about distrust of the media and distrust
of the tech companies
and destructs of the intelligence
community and president Trump embodies a
lot of these particular elements so what
do you make of the the Trump phenomenon
is a pure reaction to these things does
he have a point on some of these
elements or are we watching just
essentially the country go mad on all on
all sides what do you what do you make
of the Trump phenomena well this comes
full circle I think that the problem was
is that we didn't have something like
the IDW before this so the first person
to break through and say look the
institutions are out of control in a way
that you could actually gain power was
Trump and so as a result we associate
this kind of high level of skepticism
with Trump rather with than with the
people who might be doing it from an
incompletely responsible and
analytically sound perspective so if I
take three issues that you can take
three issues where we had what I call a
checksum theory of politics if I can see
that you're lying without doing any work
I lose trust very quickly those three
issues are as follows
first question do you believe that trade
is a rising tide that raises all boats
it clearly is not that doesn't mean it
doesn't provide a net benefit but it's
certainly in not the case that nobody
gets hurt and everybody's made better
off the representations on trade made by
economists were patently false and as
Paul Krugman is called it's basically
said it's basically a scam by the elites
second one would be immigration if you
believe that fundamentally immigrants
are simply the best of us they work
harder they're smarter they have all
these positive traits and they cause no
problem in no disruption that is
patently absurd it doesn't mean that
immigration isn't good but the
representation being made is completely
childlike the last one if you claim that
there is absolutely no connection
between terror and Islam when you have
mass murders and people shouting Allahu
Akbar at the end people know that you're
lying and this is part of the problem it
it may be very noble to protect our
Muslim community by pointing out that
the problem isn't Muslims and I I will
say the problem is not Muslims but the
problem is connected to Islam you know
in a way that it's not connected to any
other group at the moment the only two
other groups that are proud that have
practiced suicide bombing in the modern
era
Ben the Tamils in Sri Lanka I think and
the Kurds in Turkey if I'm not mistaken
I could be wrong so in these situations
with the population can clearly see that
the news media the political parties are
not representing things accurately and I
think that made people crazy they want
to believe that at least the affections
that they're being fed are adult level
and that they suggest that whatever is
being done behind the scenes even if
people can't be straight with the
population folly is still in the best
interests of the country and so I think
Trump was willing to say things in his
crass and very direct and brutal fashion
that indicated that we felt that we were
being betrayed by our institutions well
do we have a a problem though in you
make a claim that all these claims about
trade and immigration and and terrorism
that they're oversimplified and I agree
with all that obviously trade I believe
is a net benefit as you say but clearly
there are people who are going to go out
of business because of free trade I mean
there are certainly towns in the Midwest
that have gone completely out of
business they've gone to funked because
of free trade and that is one of the
cost of free trade that has always
existed and when it comes to immigration
obviously certain immigration is good
and not all immigrants are created equal
they're not they're not all the same in
terms of the qualities they bring to the
table or in terms of the culture that
they're bringing across our borders all
of that is true and then on the flip but
when you get to the flip side then
there's a miss a similarly simplistic
misrepresentation that's that's being
promulgated so when it comes to trade
for example you have people like
President Trump saying that trade is not
only a it's not just that it's it's a
net benefit that has downsides it is a
net loss that trade itself
trade wars are easy to win and good or
when he says that immigration itself is
of no benefit essentially that
immigration he wants to curb legal
immigration not just illegal immigration
and he doesn't really want to bet
anybody he just doesn't want to have a
lot of immigrants come into the country
he's pretty anti-immigration generally
speaking or when he says with regard to
the the other issues that you're talking
about when he said when he says with
regard to Islam for example well the
solution is let's ban all Muslims from
entering the country as opposed to their
problems within Islam that have to be
dealt with within Islam and we have to
vet people coming in with a certain
level of strictness he eventually comes
around to that position that's not the
original position that he's espousing
when you have to
blunt instruments slapping each other
right is there any sort of plausible
solution making that can occur I know
it's a long question which is why I'm
gonna read an ad first so before you can
think about that one
well we would get to this so first let's
talk about your suit so your suit is
probably ugly you probably got it off
the rack probably quick schlub let's be
straight about this the reality is you
need a suit from endo chino endo chino
makes made-to-measure suits and they're
made to measure not off the rack they're
made for you and every dude looks better
in a great suit and no chinos the
world's largest made-to-measure menswear
company they've been featured in major
publications including GQ & Forbes in
Fast Company to make suits and shirts
made to your exact measurements for a
great fit you can do it online you can
go to their website you send your
measurements they send you the suit made
for it you can pick your lapels you can
pick the kind of buttons you want you
pick the material they also have
headquarters in various major cities
around the country they have one on
Santa Monica Boulevard in LA I went over
there's really a lot of fun guys love
the wide selection of high quality
fabrics the options to personalize all
the details here's how it works you
visit a showroom shop online and endo
Chino calm you pick your fabric choose
the customization submit those
measurements and then wait for the
custom suit to arrive in just a few
weeks and this week my listeners can get
any premium Indo Chino suit for just 379
bucks at Indo Chino calm when you enter
Ben guessed at checkout because I have a
guest so as 50% off the regular price
for made-to-measure premium suit
shipping is free enzo Chino com promo
code been guests for any premium suit
for just 379 bucks and free shipping
incredible deal for a suit that's gonna
make you better than anything off the
rack ever could so I'm certainly totally
paranoid about my lapel ok yeah your
lapels look very nice I mean but but I
think you know Chino would make them
look better let's be straight about this
so what so with all of this said the
suggestion before the ad was basically
that both sides are now slapping each
other with these with these bricks with
these blunt instruments neither is
representing the issue fully and so you
can't have an actual honest debate about
these issues without people recognizing
the upsides and downsides of these
particular policies is there a way
forward from that or are we so ensconced
in the battle that we're just basically
this is what you and I are engaged in
this is what's so fascinating this is
what I got completely wrong ok I thought
that when we finally had Trump that the
Democratic Party who knows what's wrong
with all of these perspectives would cry
uncle and say look we have to be
straight with people because we cannot
have Donald Trump in office so if they
really think that the
sky is the second coming of Hitler and
that he's the greatest threat to world
peace that we've ever seen he's
destroying the country why not admit
that The Economist's know that it's not
a Pareto improvement where everybody
gets better off that it's only Kaldor
Hicks and that you need to tax some
winners to pay some losers or to do more
in terms of relocating people in
different sectors of the country when
you do have an open trade situation why
not instead when you when it comes to
immigration be honest with people that
fundamentally the big issue is not the
tiny efficiency gain which economists
call the harberger triangle but the
enormous thing below it called the bore
haas rectangle and it's an attempt to
use immigrants cynically to transfer
wealth from American labor to American
capital right at some level why not be
open about the fact that we actually
have a pretty good situation with the
Muslims in the US but we don't have a
highly radicalized population and that
they are in fact helping us and our
intelligence work because they speak
languages like Pashto and Farsi that we
don't speak but that there is some sort
of a problem why is it that when they
had the opportunity to take the power
away from Trump and say look okay we
oversimplified it we need to be more
honest with people so that we don't get
this reaction I thought that they would
take that opportunity the fact that they
double down on this kind of crazy
intersectional identity stuff is what's
terrifying because it seems to indicate
to us that there is no bottom there's no
way in which things get so bad that we
start leveling with people and I don't
know what to do about that I think
that's part of why we're in this IDW
thing because what we're doing in
microcosm is we're saying look I also
agree that trade can be a good thing
maybe you want a little bit more trade
than I do maybe you want a little bit
more immigration than I do I actually
published a paper that suggested how to
do open immigration using the
securitization of rights to have a true
free market so that workers benefit
alongside a capital there is zero
interest in corporate America in that
because the interest is in taking
something that belongs to labour and
handing it to capital so my feeling is
is that if you and I were to model what
a debate like that looked like it would
look absolutely nothing like what's
going on and you know this was
interesting for me when you just went on
Bill Maher after
you had been in Dave Rubin studio with
me what I saw was the the level of
distortion that happened when you went
into a formatted program Bill Maher's
about the best thing on standard
television there is and there's no way
it can compete with this long format
discussion where we actually get into
things and we don't sit here and just
beat our partisan drums so even though
I've been handed a mug that says left
this tears the fact of the matter is is
that I would much rather have a full-on
drag amount discussion about trade
immigration and terror with an honest
conservative than a somebody trying to
win an election inside of the DNC which
is why I think that you're more of a
liberal than you are a leftist you know
I don't mean liberal in the sense that
the Dave Rubin means liberal is in
classical liberal I mean that there are
people who disagree with me on economics
but agree with me that we have to
actually have honest conversations about
this stuff rather than trying to shut
this down that's why when we actually
looked at making these these tumblers
the original suggestion was liberal
tears and I said I don't want liberal
tears I want leftist years this is why I
see you as a conservative and not as a
right-wing I appreciate it so let's
let's talk about your proposal for sort
of fixing capitalism so I obviously am a
very lazy fair free market oriented guy
you have proposed something called
anthropic capitalism so what exactly
does that term mean and what does that
mean in material terms in terms of
policy well the short answer is is that
we don't know and that we better come up
with an answer quickly
what if capitalism was a pretty terrific
solution for the 19th and 20th centuries
but that in the era of let's say machine
learning and robots and world labor
markets that if you actually just let
the Machine run it doesn't deliver
enough stability and the in fact jobs
may go away because the well opportunity
being be plentiful stable repetitive
activity that's lucrative maybe in fact
quite scarce it's not at all clear to me
that if you let the wheels of capitalism
run in the current era that markets will
clear in a way that we're happy with the
way in which our resources are
distributed many people may become very
disenchanted and these are souls that
need purpose they need sustenance and
they need activity with dignity that the
market
may have provided very well in the past
so we're not going to disagree with you
about the past what I'm worried about is
the future and I think this is one of
these paradoxes where conservatives tend
to be very right about the past and
progressives if they are right tend to
be right about the fact that things may
need to be very different on a
going-forward basis well the it'll be
interesting to see as far as their view
on the right including charles Murray
and in Milton Friedman who proposed some
form of universal basic income as a
solution to the rise of artificial
intelligence and the fact that you are
having a lower skilled population that
is just not going to be able to compete
in this market where machines take over
all the truck driving for example and
all of the repetitive labor has been
taken over by radiology maybe they're
low skilled compared to a machine I mean
that's that's true too although I think
that the diagnosis seems to be better at
least from what I can see diagnosis
seems to be better when it's a
combination of machine learning and
experiencing fair enough but I'm just
trying to say that what what we define
as low skilled is gradually internet
change quite a bit right yeah I think
that the fact is is that we all
acknowledge that it has to be some kind
of a hybridized system but what I think
is also true and this is good news for
you
is is that those few people who can
actually manage these incredibly
complicated enterprises to deliver
really profound innovation and growth
may need to be freed from burdensome
regulation that's completely
inappropriate to creating new sectors of
the economy at the same time if those
windfalls occur we may need radical ways
of redistributing some of that if in
fact jobs are affected in some new way
where instead of machines having
traditionally chased us from repetitive
behavior of low value to repetitive it
behavior higher value the new paradigm
may be that all repetitive behavior is
not lucrative and that the reason that
the huge windfalls occur is is that
those people with it people mean an IQ
hierarchy as well it's not just our IQ
hierarchy it may be that what's going on
is that these are one-off special
situations so if you know they're always
some guys that you know and it's not
clear that they have a job they just
sort of meet people and they sign pieces
of paper and they make tremendous
amounts of money what are they doing
there
opportunistically searching the
landscape for things that are not
repeatable but that actually are very
well compensated most people are not
going to be in a position to do that and
I think it's very important to actually
get hyper capitalistic because we have
to deregulate certain sectors in order
to get the innovation and it's also
important to realize that we're gonna
have to do something sort of hyper
socialistic because of what you were
saying and you know if the milton
friedman's of the world have understood
that one of the things that's most
meaningful to me about these
conversations is if we get hyper
specific about what these alterations
are then perhaps we can get the
Conservatives to stop worrying quite so
much about the kind of envy driven
desire to tax where we want to punish
success because it's not fair that
certain people are doing so much better
and the Conservatives can come back and
say you know what we do have a nation of
Souls and it's not good enough to just
say well the market meets that harsh
justice so suck it tough well this is
why I think that the idea before a lot
of concerns particularly religious
conservatives is that there always has
to be a balance between liberty and
virtue that you have to have freedom in
the markets but that can't exist unless
you actually have a social fabric that's
fostered by if somebody at my synagogue
needs a hand then that person gets ahead
and that's always the way that it's it's
been in religious communities
particularly one of the great tragedies
of in my view of government growing
beyond its boundaries is that people
have stopped giving as much people have
stopped relying on their local community
or their family as much you see this
particularly with social security where
people have stopped relying on the ideal
is you had a lot of kids because your
coz we're gonna support you when you how
to hold and that your kids knew that
going in and now it's I'm supporting
your mother through social security
because you paid 50 bucks in a she's
getting two thousand bucks a month out
and so the idea of you saving until
you're really old and making plans for
that savings rates have gone down people
have stopped worrying about it cuz the
government's gonna take care of it and
it creates all of these not only in
efficiencies but perverse incentives
that result in in a lot of worse
outcomes but there's another element
here that I think is worth discussing
and that is let's say that one of things
that's happening technologically is we
are coming closer and closer to sort of
the Star Trek replicator where we've got
a machine that just makes anything right
like it's easier to buy cheap things now
than it ever has been in human history
most people can buy those things in the
United States of America the number of
people who are in extreme poverty by any
globe
standard in the United States is below
2% the vast majority of people in the
United States by global standards are
upper class and above middle to upper
classmen but by global standards not
American standards by global standards
and so we're reaching the point where
prosperity at least in any sort of
absolute sense historically is has grown
to magnificent proportions I mean the
person who's middle-class now is living
better and the person who is
unbelievably wealthy in 1880 who is
still going outside to pay or material
stand by material standards but this is
the real problem is that ubi doesn't
solve the biggest problem of all I think
which is you sort of mentioned it but
the the need for human fulfillment is
not going to be filled by a government
check or by a redistribution of income
and people so far we filled that for
most of human history we filled that
with work but the idea was that we were
going to we don't have a lot to do today
but we have to go and we have to work
these otherwise we're gonna starve and
that's what fills our days what fills
our days that we go and sure I'm doing a
repetitive task at the factory but
that's what earns me the money so I can
come home and take care of my kids and
let's just make a better life for that
and let's expand that slightly to not
only include work for from money but
also can work particularly which has
been the province more of women than of
men which has been a vital part of work
which needs to be recognized often
happens off market but you know that's
exactly right
well what and one one of the things
that's happening is in the materialist
almost Marxist perspective of whatever's
in your bank account is your is your
measure of value and that's why you know
if you don't have enough in your bank
account then obviously the system has
somehow screwed you the the reality is
that we are concerned with these
systemic problems we should focus on
these systemic problems but the great
majority of unhappiness I think that's
occurring in modern American society and
I think in the West particularly which
is historically prosperous is a poverty
of values of poverty of meaning a
poverty of purpose and I'm not sure that
that can be filled people are trying to
fill that with political action instead
of instead of trying to look at their
own lives and say what can I do to make
myself better and well if I were in down
the desert island what would I do to
make myself a better person just me and
my family what would I do other than
going and chopping down trees or
grabbing a coconut we're so focused on
either how we rail against the system
which sometimes deserves railing against
but we spend all of our time worrying
about how to rail against the system
and that I
think makes us susceptible to
politicians who lie to us about these
very simplistic well I agree - man but I
also think that one of the things that
we have to do a better job on is just as
I have to defend coming from a
left-of-center perspective the right of
people who have contributed
extraordinary levels to all of us to
retain extraordinary reward
I think it's hyper important for the
right to acknowledge that a lot of the
reward that has occurred has come from
non-productive activities through
rent-seeking so if some meeting takes
place in an investment bank which allows
them to privatize gains and socialize
whatever security is necessary to keep
those banks afloat and I wasn't party to
that that's going to make me livid and
furious whenever any orders the social
order we fully agree on this I mean when
this is it this is why we have to model
this well the Tea Party and Occupy were
on the same side of this particular
battle that our problem with occupy I
was D partyer our problem with occupy
was not their argument that the big
banks were in bed with the government
it's why are you protesting at the big
banks go protest at the government right
the big banks were not elected these the
people whom the government are elected
you want to you want to shatter that
paradigm you're actually gonna have to
go after elected officials as opposed to
yelling at bankers who don't give a crap
as they drive away in their Mercedes
yeah I'm actually more upset about the
people who've both left and right
refused to talk about the problem of
rent-seeking so I believe there was a
speech that Hillary Clinton gave at some
point if I'm not mistaken where she said
come on we we all created the great
financial crisis I thought no we don't
really didn't all create the greatest
potential crisis and whether that is the
heads of investment banks or politicians
or the rating agencies whatever it is we
did not return costs in an appropriate
fashion and that is the problem why
there is such loss of trust when we have
the savings and loan scale you have
situations where people go to jail when
people do jail time for bad deeds you
have a public trust that people can see
that that the high-and-mighty can be
laid low what was astounding and then
you know this is one of the things where
to distrust the New York Times as I
appeared in an article called they tried
to outsmart Wall Street which tried to
make the case that it was not the
investment bankers but the quants who
came from mathematics and physics who
caused the crisis when from my
perspective we were the guys who tried
to sound the alarm and say hey the
models are out of control and this is
nuts and nobody listened to us so it's
very important to realize that the media
gets into the act the regulator's the
ratings agencies the politicians there's
this entire industry of people that
ordinary Americans do not understand
cannot fathom that is allowing rent
seeking to undermine the basis of wealth
and it's important that wealth be
something we can understand I always
watch Jackie Chan when he does a reel of
the stunts in his film that didn't go
well and he slides down you know live
electrical wire and breaks through a
glass and I think there's no way in the
world I want to tax this guy at a high
level and take his money because I know
exactly why he got paid because I would
never do any of me I want to be able to
point to fortunes and say I know what
this person created and thank you and
it's very important that we restore
confidence that rent-seeking is not the
primary modality by which wealth is
created through transfer all right so
let's talk a little bit about how people
find fulfilling lives because this is
one of the other elements of the IDW is
we all start off talking about these
sorts of political issues and how to
solve systemic problems and one of the
things that's fun about it is that we
discover that we have so much common
ground on a lot of these issues but
there's some of that some of the more
the most interesting conversations have
happened over even deeper issues so you
and i and sam harris we're all on stage
together in san francisco and we ended
up in a two hour long conversation about
everything from freewill to morality and
values and the argument that i've been
making is one of the things that's
broken in the West is that there is not
a common sense of values anymore that
that has basically been shattered that
even even though Sam and I hold a lot of
values in common
the place we get those values is very
different and I frankly don't understand
how Sam gets to his values from his own
perspective is basically a materialist
neurobiologist it doesn't make it
doesn't make a whole hell of a lot of
sense to me so how do we find that set
of common values
should we just stop asking the question
basically should I just be happy the Tam
and I agree on the stuff and then we and
then we sort of let it go at that I'm
happy to do that but I'm not sure that I
think that the reason in my perspective
that we argue about this stuff is
because I think that Sam's perspective
on values well I agree with his values
are unsustainable in the long run that
it's not sustainable beyond the people
who really like Sam and follow Sam
whereas I think that at least trying to
appeal to some source of objective
morality that's beyond my own reason is
is replicable and has been replicable
throughout human history yeah this is an
interesting question I mostly stayed out
of it because I think that the audience
probably wanted to see the atheist and
the guy right in claws go exactly but I
had a very different take I think than
both of you and I came at it from sort
of a evolutionary biology perspective
for my perspective the key issue is is
that Sam begins with some concept which
he calls human flourishing which I don't
know has ever fully fleshed out and from
what I can tell the great danger with
humans is is that we can wake up and
look at theories of selection and say oh
my gosh this is the game that brought us
here and even if evolution is the engine
that created us we don't need to keep
playing that game so for example we
don't need to have children because we
have birth control so even if we want to
have sex we can get involved in and
break that linkage and these are things
or have to do with the way in which the
human body is constructed we think about
proximate and ultimate approximate is
thirst but the ultimate is dehydration
approximate is hunger but the ultimate
you know is lack of nutrition right so
what happens is is that what happens if
the mind suddenly wakes up and decides
that it wants to pursue proximate
pleasure and if you break the body into
two kinds of tissue soma and germ you
the germ is your lineage what
contributes to your having children and
that is the thing that is immortal but
the soma is disposable and so we're all
in danger that the soma that is our mind
[Music]
can wake up and say hey I just want to
have fun and I want to have pleasure I'm
gonna define human flourishing to be
whatever it is that I particularly enjoy
now it's not true that every atheist is
gonna go crazy like far from it but the
problem is is that it doesn't
necessarily scale so I'm in the odd
position of basically being an atheist
who is very sympathetic to religion and
who in fact attends you know services
and has a temple in large measure
because I believe that the brain has a
sort of Chomsky and pre grammar of
religion and that is that what what
sustained us was a belief in something
longer than our somatic lives we all
feel that usually in terms of our
children even atheists but the key
question is let's imagine that you don't
have any children are you going to make
investments that are going to benefit
future generations if you don't believe
that there's anything that happens after
you die and there's no purpose and
there's no meaning so the way in which
it comes down for me is is that the
reason religions out-compete rationality
which is quite surprising if you if you
think about it is this issue that the
religions keep soma from waking up and
redefining human flourishing to be
somatic and that is probably the thing
that I think Sam has not fully addressed
now Sam is the unusual because he is the
atheist who sees the value in religion
clearly and says I think we can
accomplish all that religion does well
from the perspective of of reason so
it's not that we have to convince him
that religions do many things well but
we have to convince him of is is that it
may be the case that certain aspects of
atheist seeing human flourishing as
intergenerational lineage level behavior
maybe that doesn't scale and it only
scales when you actually believe that
there's some meaning and purpose that's
larger than yourself so obviously I
agree with a lot of that and I think
that this is the the flaw in Tim's
reasoning is not his questioning of
faith per se it's his faith in reason
alone and the idea that by reason alone
you can achieve whatever values Sam
wants you to achieve and and that I find
deeply problematic especially because we
had two hundred years where people were
basically trying this and it did not
work out particularly well but it may be
that for example that religion served us
better in the past but that Sam is right
about our future
even if we don't have an atheist scale
plan I mean it could be that we could
Institute rituals that are actually
devoid of a belief in the supernatural
that take over the chomskyan pre grammar
I'm not saying that that's for closeable
but is it was he was a giant fail for
200 years
ma'am I am an adult of Reason in France
we had it we had essentially a communist
ritual system and I don't I don't
believe the argument that we should
treat Russia
Sophia Russia as a religion and
therefore it's not an experiment with
the failure of atheism I think that
these there's great danger in religion
there's great danger in an absence of
religion and what's really necessary is
to move that conversation in which our
values are embedded even if we're
atheistic because we're benefiting from
the fact that we come from a substrate
that was there was a largely
judeo-christian social system and I
agreed with you and by the way I really
appreciated your willingness to forego
any appeal to Torah or Bible in favor of
a really appeal to reason for religion I
think that was really interesting I mean
there's it because otherwise we have no
common frame of reference for the
conversation so I may find that stuff
inspiring and meaningful but Sam clearly
does I'm quoting him from the Bible who
cares I mean he's not gonna he's not
gonna resonate to that and it's not
gonna be an argument that's that's
necessarily worth winning with his
audience because how do I win by citing
Leviticus like this that's just not it's
not a winning argument well particularly
Deuteronomy really loses me of the thing
that really gets that really gets me
about some of the conversations that
we're having is that you have a very
large number of people in our network I
would say Brett Weinstein you me Jordan
maybe Douglas Murray who I think are
quite sympathetic to religion without
making arguments from religion I think
everybody in the group basically if they
were willing to admit it would would if
they're willing to admit I think pretty
much everybody who were talking about is
essentially a natural law theologian the
only question is whether you're cutting
God out of the picture or not
well because Sam is basically making a
natural law argument he's just he's he's
saying this is the universe calls us to
you know essentially forward human
flourishing and then I just have a
problem with his definition well but but
the problem would be you
and I don't want to have to ask you
about this on camera but if I said you
know how sure are you about the truth of
the revelation at Sinai I'm not entirely
sure that you could give me a basis for
that nor what I want I can't give you a
rational basis for revelation and sign
it right and so the best that I can do
is sort of Maimonides explanation which
is that something happened at Sinai and
I'm not sure quite what and people got
from that is what he says and guide for
the perplexed and when people got from
that is there is a God and there
shouldn't be idolatry which human reason
can bring you to and then that Moses was
a particularly inspired logical figure
who was able to access higher modes of
thinking and brings the Torah down from
from Sinai through direct communication
with God that's essentially my natis his
argument and I'm worried about even that
so in some sense if I am feeling sick
and I go to the drugstore and I say
don't you guys have a placebo you can
give me that can cure my ailment if I'm
really in on the conceit that I don't
have to you know fully believe something
it's not clear to what effect you know
that it may be that you really get the
benefit from being certain that there
was a revelation at Sinai and so the
question of self-deception and its
efficacy in human flourishing is that is
a very interesting one no this is it and
I think this is a key question is sort
of broken out is you have to believe in
the reality of Revelation or just the
importance of Revelation and my belief
is that you sort of have to believe that
at minimum you have to believe in the
importance if you if you believe in the
reality so much better because then you
have it easier but believing in the
importance is the minimum of
understanding the evolution of Western
civilization and then you have a
situation in which you probably need a
super position of belief and lack of
belief in order to have a decent life
that's probably always existed but one
of the things that's so odd about this
is that it's hard to talk about without
destroying the efficacy and these sort
of questions of self contemplation when
you're trying to solve this thought from
is problem may have something to do with
the limits of discourse and I think that
you know this is something that would be
much more interesting to model than the
usual dorm level discussions about
whether there's a god yeah I think
that's exactly right well all of this is
really fascinating so let's let's finish
X we're getting close to the end here
let's talk for just a second about if
you could make three changes to the
country what would those three changes
be well probably ins the Barbara Walters
whatever kind of tree question but
that's alright
regular investigation of the
intelligence community so that if they
are in fact doing a fantastic job we can
all rely on them because I think that
they provide a vital service and I'm not
against them a we need to pay
journalists a great deal more I don't
know where that money is going to come
from and then we need to fire them at
the drop of a hat when they really break
trust by pursuing ideology as part of
their payment psychic payments stream at
the expense of truthful and meaningful
reporting and I think that it's
absolutely imperative that the
scientific apparatus of the United
States be restored through academic
freedom so that we can have crazy
dangerous highly agenting people once
again take back the labs and kick out
all of the safe and ideologically driven
alterations so that we can create the
new sectors of the economy to get growth
back on track and this is one of the
things that I think Peter Thiel and I
share deeply which is people don't worry
enough about what happens in the absence
of growth and the u.s. absolutely needs
in the world at large to find non-fossil
fuel LED technological broadly
distributed stable growth in order to
avert war and maybe the fourth and most
crazy suggestion if you don't mind me
sneaking it in is once in a blue moon I
think we need to explode an above-ground
nuclear weapon because I'm terrified
that what's happened is is that we've
all fallen under a spell of magical
thinking that it doesn't matter who we
elect and it doesn't matter how bad
things get that somehow the world is
bizarrely stable and safe and it
absolutely is not and I think maybe we
need to actually activate the amygdala
and remind everybody with what is
hanging in the balance and house
unstable this is so we can get on to the
bit to the business of making a really
beautiful planet for generations to come
Eric Weinstein thanks so much for
stopping by I was great to see you it's
always fun to talk with my friends and
it's cool to have a friend in here Eric
thanks so much for stopping by
it's been
[Music]
avenge hero shows Sunday special is
produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy boring associate
producers Mathis Glover and Austin
Stevens edited by Alex Singaram audio is
missed by Mike Carmina hair and makeup
is by Jess wah alvera and title graphics
by Cynthia and Gullu the Ben Shapiro
shows Sunday special is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright
Ford publishing 2018
[Music]
you